>> Gaymers, charge your brofist
Cause we're about to play them ultimate
bro game of all time
~Tuber Simulator!!!~
Now, I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But this is clearly
the greatest game of all time
Now we kinda memed the whole thing
That uhh it's becoming relevant again
.. It is actually becoming ..
No! No don't leave!
No please! And uhh sad to say
I'm not even replaying my own game
Shameful. So I thought
It's about God damn time
I jump back into Pewdiepie's Tuber Simulator.
It's been a while, it's been a while.
By the way, if you
haven't play the game in a while it's so
easy to recover your old UHH
Account just from your Google Account or whatever
you were registered on. I got my Pewdiepie
Account back. I thought I would have to ask
uhh Outerminds the developers if
they could help me but no it's super easy
Dude, I gained 7 million views
when I was away. What is this? PaThEtIc.
Goddamit, this my room looks so ugly
So we try to recreat set-up i've had here
I can't imagine
Okay, well .. so the current theme is si-fi everyone
so for thoso you who don't know how this games works
It's basically a youtuber simulator (*no way*)
you make videos .. emm .. wich video i'm gonna make
.. Argue with your intelligent home -ha-
O'h rly?
So there is new items
oh my god what is that ?
I want it
Iay wanyyt
*inhalates*
.. 14 houres, *KS voice* are you kidding me?
(*felix fantasy s1e2*)
GOOD ONE
(HIS VOICE IS LITARALY SAME AS IN THIS mob game app with couple)
I 'll heart that ..